back in like late 90s trading desk was
like a locker room it was very like
Alpha driven a lot of hazing and [__]
but I mean I was at the time boxing for
the New York Athletic Club I had played
hockey I mean I was I worked in a prison
for four years so these nerds were
hazing me and one day I just cuffed the
guy I just slapped him across the face
and almost knocked him out of his seat
and needless to say they fired me but I
was covering these young guys at Enron
and they told the senior Traders what
had happened
and one of the senior traders who
happened to be from Martha's Vineyard
outside of Boston called me up said hey
I got a job I didn't even know we had
competitors that's how naive I was I
didn't know the other brokerage shops I
was there like two months and um I mean
I barely knew what had been an offer was
were and um this other competitor
offered me a job starting the next
Monday
[Music]
all right we get right into this Ken uh
thanks for coming man I uh do you know
at all what you're getting into or no
yeah yeah I heard uh Andrew huberman on
the show my friend Andrew
good well let me um I'll let you kind of
do the intro but I want to tell our
audience what I know about you and why I
think it's cool that we have you
basically I was telling Sean
you're so we take pride in like finding
people a little bit before they explode
you're getting quite popular you're in
the Wall Street Journal the other day so
things are happening for you but you're
to me like you're like the next David
Goggins in my mind like you know you're
kind of a freak athletically but you're
also more so a freak mentally and you
talk about a lot of like just being
tough you got some crazy quotes that uh
we'll talk about later about how uh
uh you know like you like running
because it's all about suffering and
things like that and so you said a lot
of really interesting things Sean and I
are also a huge combat sports fans so I
listen to the pie with Teddy Atlas that
you're on and I know a bit about your
background and so I wanted to have you
on to talk about that typically we talk
about business stuff huberman was a
little bit of a we had him on and that
was a little non-business you're a
little bit non-business but you had like
a interesting background where you
worked on Wall Street worked on worked
at Enron I think you did a bunch of
interesting stuff and so
that's kind of why we had you on what um
how do you give your introduction what
do you what do you say you do yeah well
thank you for that introduction uh when
I hear people introduce me sometimes I
almost don't feel like they're talking
about me because
I I think part of what makes me unique
is I at times have don't have the
highest opinion of myself and always
feel like I there's I should be doing
more but um I think that the comparison
to David Goggins is somewhat accurate
although
it's accurate I can see why others would
think that but I don't think that
it's a perfect and I take it as a
compliment no I don't think he's soft at
all I think he's probably maybe more
more aggressive and uh Alpha than I am I
would say I try to be
I don't know I think that the way I come
across you know when I was on Rich Roll
he described me as being his his initial
impression of me prior to meeting me was
that I was very aggressive and uh Alpha
and intimidating and I don't see myself
that way I see why other people would
see that but I think of myself as that
that alpha or aggressive exterior is
almost like a defense mechanism because
inside I think I'm very emotional and
sensitive and so much so that my way of
protecting that sensitivity is to be so
aggressive externally that it really
takes someone unique and special to kind
of see through it
um at least that's my take from uh the
the the Psychotherapy I've been involved
in but the reason and the reason we had
you on we typically so it's usually just
Sean and I or it's like we'll have like
billionaires and stuff on so like these
like a wonderful people but
something that like I've been thinking a
lot about lately and I've been talking
to Sean about lately it's just like
toughness and like how it feels like
good to get out there and work hard
physically or to spar do things like
that because even though we're doing
cool [__] behind the computer it's still
behind the computer and it feels good to
live and you say you're not an alpha but
I think in the Wall Street Journal
article you said uh I'm the biggest male
I'm the biggest alpha male on the
starting line I'm ready thank you for
pointing that out because there was
context to that quote I said my my exact
quote was when I'm on the out when I'm
on the start line when it's time to go
100 I'm Alpha I will step on your neck
to win I want to kill you I want to
destroy everyone but the minute that
race is over I'm everyone's best friend
if I see someone fall down in front of
me I will stop and help them I've in
triathlons I've asked people yo man you
all right I'll stop and help you I'm not
I say step on your neck and kill you to
win but not really like this is
this is my mental process that I have to
go through to get to the dark place that
I need to get to to suffer to the extent
that I need to suffer to get the most
out of myself running you know I ran uh
36 hours ago I ran the Tokyo marathon in
229.19 and the day before that and the
day before that outside magazine wrote
an article how 51 year old can ride out
run sub 230 marathons and I saw the
headline and I literally had an anxiety
attack I'm like oh my god oh the
pressure is on I mean I've run some 230
three or four times but it ain't easy
and I know that that last five or six
miles the suffering and the Darkness
that's coming with that I can't it's
it's literally the physically the
hardest things that I've ever done is
like you everything in your body would
be like if you're driving your car in
every single warning dollars going off
the radiator is overheating the oil's
low you're gonna run out of gas and you
literally are like I can stop and no one
would care or I can push myself and know
that I didn't have another F and ounce
to give and that's it sounds cliche or
might sound corny but that's my process
that's where I have to go to get to
where I've gone to it's to the point
where guys like you with this awesome
plugins want to talk to me like I'm I'm
a regular guy I'm a dope I I don't see
myself as special with the exception of
being willing
to die to get the most out of myself
physically on these particular days at
races and you so you said you just ran
you just ran the a marathon in Tokyo 36
hours ago you're here now and I didn't
know much about you before Sam brought
it up Sam goes oh I really want to have
this guy on are you down with it I
thought I
I've heard that name but I don't know
who is that and I was like oh is that
the Teddy Atlas podcast guy oh wait
what's the story and I as I started
looking into it to me there was a few
things that really stood out so there's
the kind of the obvious headline that
here's a guy who's over 50 years old and
is basically flying through these
marathons they're running super fast
speeds I don't know the exact records or
whatnot but you're one of the fastest if
not the fastest corrected you're kind of
in your brand over 50. yep yeah so
that's kind of remarkable and I think
that's you know that's the key thing I
want to get to is like that's an
extraordinary thing and that doesn't
just come out of nowhere and so uh you
talk about being able to go to that
place at the last five miles what
happens pre-race where do you where how
do you flip that switch what is your
sort of like um uh mental state of mind
or your psyche what do you do mentally
to prep yourself before these races
those are great questions and thank you
for the opportunity to explain this
because I think that it's um important
for people to understand when they look
at this just on the surface like you
just described like wow it's
extraordinary and by the way when I hear
it it doesn't even seem like you're
talking about me so I I I I don't
at times have the highest opinion on
myself because of the struggles I've
gone through with addiction so as I'm
telling you this I'm super
conscious that about coming across like
a narcissist I don't want to come across
like that I want to be I want to be very
humble in how I describe this but I'm
going to be honest with the process
prior to the race
I've spent before a race and this one in
particular not no different than any
other I spent 10 or 12 weeks like
devoting all my physical energy or or at
least 90 minutes to two and a half hours
a day of preparing for this for let's
say 12 weeks
when I get to Tokyo the week before I
always go by myself my wife I have four
young children even some of the local
Races they don't come to even when I
think oh I'm gonna win and you can see
me win a race like they've come to a few
of them and it's kind of uneventful for
them they come to expect me to win and I
in my mind think they're going to be so
psyched when they see me win and then
they're like okay Dad can we get out of
here now and get a donut so um anyway
long-winded way to say I have a very um
uh very specific process that I have to
go through in the days leading up and
again I don't want to sound like I'm
like some Elite professional Runner but
this is how this is what I do this is
the process I have to get there in the
case of Tokyo with a 14 15 hour time
change I need to get there at least
seven days early to get my body and my
circadian rhythm on track with what I'm
about to do because again I've spent 12
weeks devoting so much energy to this I
don't want to mess around when I get
there it's very specific I don't make
plans to go to dinner with people or
very rarely mainly because I'm a jerk I
know it I'm very selfish to me again I'm
not a pro Runner but to me this is my
version of the Olympics and I am not
there to mess around and have fun it's
uh like I'm I'm on a work trip so I get
there and I just need to be alone by
myself think about what I want to do try
to stay positive uh I'm a big believer
in mindset and and what you tell
yourself is the truth reality doesn't
matter like what other people think
about you does it matter it's the only
thing that matters what you think of
yourself and that goes into the same
that same thought process goes into
preparing for this race in my mind I am
a professional Runner and I'm going to
win the you know Olympic gold medal on
Sunday so I get there early I go through
my process and on race day I've said
this before in interviews it's like I'm
not I'm nothing nice on race day I don't
want to make friends I don't want to
chit chat I don't I'm a jerk I know it
so I try to stay completely by myself I
don't put my [__] on other people but I
don't want them putting theirs on me
either so I stay by myself the race goes
off I know what's coming some people are
like how are the sites in Tokyo what
were the people like in the race I said
I couldn't tell you if we ran through
the friggin Imperial Palace or not all I
know is the road in front of me and I
get into like a tunnel vision where I
can't see
any I mean I obviously if I look around
I could but I don't waste an ounce of
energy I don't even try to look at my
watch for I don't want to move any
movement that isn't completely necessary
to get from A to B as quickly as
possible I'm trying to run the
straightest line I'm focusing if people
get too close to me I'll like kind of
give them and I'm like dude you're
getting too close like I don't want to
trip someone at the start of the race in
Tokyo I was on right on the start line
at two or three people right in front of
me toppled and it was like they were
caught in the whitewashes Surfers just
arms and legs flailing elbows and knees
smashing on the ground as people just
trample them at the front of a major
Marathon it was crazy so I don't want
them doing that to me so I'm like that's
what I meant about being a bit Alpha at
the start but I don't want to hurt
anyone I don't want to affect anyone but
I don't want to be effed with either
um and uh did I see uh did I see a
picture of of you and Jason calcanus
over there yeah I mean Jake Jacob yeah
it's my dude how do you know him Kate my
friend Casey neistat who is uh do you
know who he is uh YouTube uh Casey so I
trained Casey last year for the New York
Marathon my friend Neve Schulman who's
the host of Catfish on MTV he connected
us so I trained Jason and uh not Jason
uh Casey and Neve for New York City
marathon and then I heard Jason
mentioning
um running a marathon on on all in and I
just mentioned it in passing to Casey
Casey connected me I saw Jason was in it
with connected via text I saw Jason was
in Tokyo I sent him a text and then we
ended up going to dinner one night and
then a Tokyo food tour the next day we
went to like some super high-end sushi
place and then a bakery and Jay Cal is
like he's dialed he knows where he wants
to go I know nothing hey I was just like
just tell me where we're going and I'll
be there just text me the address
um that's what I mean about the week
you're in the crowd you're you're
hanging out with all the all the cool
guys again when I think about my friends
like Andrew huberman and David Sinclair
and Joe Rogan I think I can't believe
these guys are my friends I'm I I feel
like the luckiest person in the world
and I'm so humbled and honored that guys
like you want to talk to me it's just
mind-blowing but it comes back to this
point of
I don't have anything that anyone
listening to this show doesn't have I
promise you I'm not a good athlete I
play division three Sports I was just a
hustler and when I found running as a
way of getting over an addiction issue
with opio opioids I just decided I was
done being mediocre and we'll get into
the career stuff and I'll tell you how I
did applied the same practice to my
career in finance but at the end of the
day you know not again not to sound
cliche but if you're not all in there's
just too many competitors out there that
are going to eat your lunch if you don't
bring your A game every day but when you
do dedicate your 100 effort to one
particular goal it's very hard to beat
the guy who wants to die to win and
that's kind of what I applied to running
and and it's attracted these other kind
of people that recognize that I am like
serious about the things that I get
involved in
well the thing that you're interesting
is the you just have an interesting life
did I read did you used to work at Enron
no good question I I was working in
finance my very first job if you want me
to kind of walk through my career I
don't want to like jump around I started
in I moved to New York right after I
graduated college I had a pharmaceutical
sales job for a few months but when I
moved to New York I saw all these
younger guys my age working in finance
and making a ton of money and I was like
I was making like thirty six thousand
dollars in my like rent and student
loans came to more than my take-home pay
I was basically like living on borrowed
time
in New York living in a shitty walk up
and um long story short I was playing uh
pick up ice hockey at Chelsea Piers and
a French Canadian kid
who played uh minor league hockey asked
me if I wanted a job as a um like a
trading assistant on a on an inter-deal
or brokerage desk brokering uh
electricity trades between the utilities
and Enron was one of those clients and
the way it worked was the junior guys at
Enron would trade like next day power
which was like the commission was like
literally like five dollars but if you
didn't do that as a service for these
accounts they weren't going to trade the
like big ticket items with you so long
story short I was doing that the guys on
the trading desk you know back in like
the late 90s trading desk was like a
locker room it was very like
Alpha driven
um a lot of hazing and [__] but I mean I
was at the time boxing for the New York
Athletic Club I had played hockey I mean
I was I worked in a prison for four
years so these nerds were hazing me and
one day I just cuffed the guy I just
slapped him across the face and almost
knocked him out of his seat and needless
to say they fired me but I was covering
these young guys at Enron and they told
the senior Traders what had happened
and one of the senior traders who
happened to be from Mazda's Vineyard
outside of Boston called me up said hey
I got a job I didn't even know we had
competitors that's how naive I was I
didn't know the other brokerage shops I
was there like two months and um I mean
I barely knew what a bitten an offer was
what were and um this other competitor
offered me a job starting the next
Monday I was making 40 Grand they
offered me a job at 80 grand I mean to
me that was more money than anyone I
knew made so I was like and the other
thing is this guy's hazing me I had a
huge black guy from a flight at the New
York Athletic Club like I was not like a
punk that you could just like I didn't
strike you come across as like Hey Bully
me I'm a big [__] like I was a guy you
know so when he did it I was like you
got the wrong guy dude and I cracked him
and needless to say he almost started
crying because I was like when you leave
this office I'm gonna beat that crap out
of you and he's like I'm not I'm not
gonna leave I go you're gonna have to
sleep here because when you come outside
you're getting a beaten and they were
like okay Ken you got to go before we
call the clops and again I had no safety
net I couldn't call home and ask for
money that was like I work in the prison
my stepdad and brother were inmates in
the prison no one was looking to help me
in my finance career in New York to them
I was like an anomaly you know I was
already like the richest person they
knew just by having a job in New York
City
so um yeah it was nerve-wracking and uh
so that's how my career started and the
guys at Enron were just like good
customers of my clients that like
literally changed my life but it worked
out all right I mean I think at the end
of your career I mean you're killing it
yeah so so when that happened I mean
when from the minute that happened
within
two years I was making like I mean not
again not sound like a narcissist and I
don't have a lot of money I don't I'm
not a rich guy but within two years I
was making like two million dollars a
year doing things that to me were like I
didn't even know what we were trading I
just knew people and I had relationships
and they were just doing trades with me
I was living in London I was running uh
I ran sales and trading commodity sales
and trading at Kenner Fitzgerald out of
London in Hong Kong and I was flying on
the Concorde back and forth from New
York to London on a regular basis every
single time the novelty like just never
wore off every time it happened I was
like I can't believe that this is my
life much like I feel today I can't
believe I've done this how are you
making that much money that's just
commissions or uh yeah so what goes into
that how do you jump from like 80k to 2
million what what happened yeah good
question so um I was brokering um
electricity trades and electricity
deregulation had just taken place so
you're putting together trades for like
Commodities trade on monthly contracts
so we were doing that and um when Enron
went went bust I got basically sent from
New York from at London back to New York
because the business had dried up but I
was like one of the biggest producers of
commissions at the time
again like I was so unqualified I didn't
know anything about the technicalities
of what we were doing I just knew how to
find buyers and sellers it could have
been houses it could have been baseball
cards I just was had a knack for it is
that like so when networking is it cold
calling what were you what were you
doing to actually be great what did it
take to be great there yeah good
question I hate the word networking I
feel like when you're trying to network
you're already like us behind the curve
like if you're trying to make friends
people ask me frequently now like how
are you friends with Rich Roll and and
uh Andrew and I'm like I don't know I
just I I must have something that they
like and they have something I like we
just find each other but I certainly
didn't make a conscious effort ever to
be friends with anyone it's just a
natural process so
to answer your question I just had I
just had an ability to connect with
people and I tried to have live a life
of honesty and integrity and if I say
I'm gonna do something I'll do it and I
like to tell the people that I'm close
with or when I have a close friend
someone's like oh are you friends with
that guy I'm like oh I'd help that guy
bury a dead body I like him so much like
that's my guy you know and I think that
people know people that are my friends
know that that's the truth if you need
me someone's coming to over to your
house they want to fight with you I'll
come and help you like and I think like
I said I think the people who are tight
with me they know that that's a
character trait that I have and I think
it's what's helped me build the rapport
with the people that I've built rapport
with
um but to your question
um so I had this ability to connect with
people so when Enron went bust they sent
me back to New York and again talking
about Reinventing yourself Enron goes
down I'm making a ton of money and these
businesses like Tanner Fitzgerald
investment Banks Etc they're ruthless so
the minute [__] went sideways with
electricity trading they were like okay
we'll send you back to New York and this
was I lived in London during 9 11 and
Canada was on the top floor of the World
Trade Center so when we lost 3 000
people they sent me back to New York and
said hey can you take over our credit
derivatives business which happened to
be the most lucrative business in the in
the institution at the time now if I
didn't know anything about electricity
you can imagine how little I knew about
credit derivatives I knew less than
nothing I knew as much as
a plumber wouldn't it
but I knew people and I knew the lingo
and I just I picked up the phone and
just in hindsight I don't even know I
had a I developed a relationship with
a guy who's still one of my really good
friends called Colin Stewart who worked
at Morgan Stanley who happened to be a
huge Trader of these things and then
Market was so new
credit derivatives and we just hit it
off again just became friendly we went
skiing a couple times and um he started
to just do a ton of business with me and
at the time when a product is new the
commissions tend to be big until people
realize how much they're paying on an
annual monthly or annual basis
but I can remember one time for context
and again I'm only sharing these numbers
because of the the context of the
podcast I I don't want to come across
like hey look how much money I'm making
because hey our podcast is called it's
called my first millionaire all right
all right so I'm on a trading desk
there's a group of credit derivative
Brokers just generic credit derivatives
I was trading credit derivative like
correlation products like super
sophisticated high-end bespoke one-off
trades
so the credit derivative desk has like
12 guys and that was like the product du
jour everyone wanted to be in credit
derivatives it was jam and they were
credit derivative basically think of it
as an option on a bond so these guys
would jam in and we had a super busy day
one day everyone did and the kid who ran
the CDs credit default swap death says
to me dude we had a huge day we made 250
000 in commissions between like 10 15
guys so I said hold on let me see and I
start telling everything I go oh dude I
I was a one-man show I said I did uh 262
000 in total commissions and I think I
was keeping like either 50 or 60 of that
in one day
ha
amazing uh it was insane and so how did
you how did you leave that why how do
you let that go or you know what
happened yeah take us yeah continue the
story all right so
when I went to London I was in charge of
like a bunch of grown men and and I was
like 27 years old but I was very
immature like when I went to college
I've said in previous interviews like I
I wasn't prepared for adulthood I I just
I grew up around junkies and degenerates
and like it was a very hectic childhood
and my brother was in and out my brother
never went to school past the ninth
grade he's only 11 months younger than
me so it was just total chaos where I
was and I just knew I had to get out of
this so I applied to college like I
literally went to the school I went to
because on the application you could
like fill in the little dots with the
pencil next to the letters and it was
like like path of least resistance in
terms of applications
and I could work it and I had a job
offer to work as a guard in the prison
full-time in the summer and then a few
days a week during the school year which
I did through college
I started at the prison like when I was
uh one week out of high school so if you
can imagine being in a men's Maximum
Security Prison I mean I was 18 but I
probably looked like I was 15. but I
also knew prison is very segregated
right blacks and whites don't
necessarily mingle with each other
freely it's not like it's it's like a
different world but I knew most of the
white guys because I grew up in like
white Irish Catholic almost like not in
housing projects my whole life but in
that in that sphere so when I got there
I knew some of those guys so I wasn't as
scared as I might be if I didn't know
anyone going in there which I know
sounds crazy in hindsight now people
know me like you knew people in prison
I'm like the difference between guards
and inmates is like the inmates have
been caught the guards are just as bad
it's like that was that was a big part
of my motivation to get out of college
it's like looking at what my prospects
of Life looked like if I didn't go to
college and working at that prison I was
like I'd rather be dead it was the worst
worst
to this day it's the worst experience of
my life just in the thought of having to
do that every day for 20 years
so um
I'm working there paying through college
I'm I go to London I'm now in charge of
basically in in on a brokerage desk
whoever makes the most commissions
they're the manager regardless of having
management skills so I guess what I was
saying in a long-winded way of saying
like I had no experience or no I didn't
have the maturity to be a manager so I
really didn't know what I was doing but
I knew I was good at brokering trades
and I was suffering massively like from
a fraud complex imposter syndrome and I
had a minor surgery on my ankle I was
introduced to Percocet and the minute I
took those Percocets and the opioids I
was like oh I have all the confidence in
the world no one can stop me
and thus began like a 10-year
Odyssey of being high 24 7. save for
like a week or two here a month here and
there like I'd get sober on my own just
White Knuckle it like go through the
physical withdrawals of you know
basically opioids just like heroin I was
I was a mess like in hindsight I I tell
people now when I speak to like junkies
at like n a meetings like AAA meetings I
speak at prisons I say like
I was a good drug addict I could get
away with it I had resources I was
resourceful I could find drugs anywhere
I could get people to give me
prescriptions all over the country I
just I'm embarrassed to say I was really
good at it and I was a functioning
addict for a good 10 years and I'm sure
people that worked with me during those
during that period just think I was
[__] crazy not necessarily whacked on
drugs but it is what it is it's
embarrassing like I'm I
I get choked up thinking about it
because
I I just can't believe I behaved like
such a loser and um but I did it and um
and once I finally
um got sober
um when we started when I I started
having children with my wife I have an
adopted daughter who's 12 years old from
we adopted her from Ethiopia as a
newborn and right before we adopted her
I just went through like an outpatient
detox got clean and have been sober
since I mean I haven't been without slip
UPS over the last several years like I
might you know slip up here in there but
I mean for the most part I've been sober
longer than I've ever been in my life
and it's um you know it's like of all
the things I've ever done it's the one
of the things that I'm most proud of the
fact that I was able to
um kind of I don't say get over because
it's a constant struggle to stay sober
when you've been addicted to those kind
of drugs they're so physically and and
um mentally addictive
um but nevertheless it is that that's
kind of my journey but um where'd the
transition go from just being a normal
guy to this kind of I don't know
personality or whatever you want to call
what you are now yep that's what I was
going to get to so in 2010 when I got
sober I started doing um triathlons I
did the Iron Man in Hawaii three times
it was your first time or what was what
what time did you finish in your first
uh Triathlon uh probably 11 hours and
then oh you broke 12 hours your first
time yeah yeah but that's like that
again that goes back to mentality like
oh my God by the way Sean that's like
pretty good I mean 12 hours sounds like
a very long time somebody's number no
breaking 12 hours for your first time
that's like uh that's a that's a great
accomplishment right pretty good in like
three years I got down to a 936
basically without even knowing how to
swim and I went to Hawaii three times
but again part of that Journey was like
learning about myself and figuring out
how to suffer and
learning that quitting is much harder
than suffering because the first time I
went to Hawaii to me it was like I had
um made it to the Olympics and I was so
happy just to be there that when when I
got off the bike you know it's two and a
half miles swim in the ocean 112 mile
bike ride in the Hawaii sun in the Heat
and you start a marathon around one
o'clock in the afternoon
which would be crazy even even to do as
a training run and um The Run got hard
and I just quit I just stopped I was
like I'm dying this isn't my day of like
I I just told myself every story that I
needed to tell myself to justify
quitting it's been a long year of
training you made it here that's the big
thing and as I walked back to transition
literally like crying to myself like
crying like real tears like it just it's
so shameful because I knew I didn't have
to quit I had a lot more to get even if
I walked and um I went back the next
year and finished in like 9 hours and 39
minutes which was you know I don't know
where I finished overall but that that
was it I was very satisfied with that
and that process of so so I used the
Endurance Sports to deal with my
addiction and then through Endurance
Sports I discovered my an ability to
suffer through adversity and I also
learned the pain of quitting and the
emptiness that I felt when I didn't give
a hundred percent to something that I
had committed to and um and that really
began the journey so that was like in
2012 or 13 where I was like you know
what I'm done being mediocre at anything
in life I'm whatever I do I'm gonna do
with a hundred percent conviction
including work and if you're like I'm
happy to come back to like my career and
how I transitioned into what it was into
what it is because this is all part of
the same story well let's stay with the
with the Mind shift so I want to talk
about two of them so you had said kind
of like uh we adopted my daughter and I
decided to get sober and you know uh
made a decision but what what was the
thought
uh because you know after 10 years of
addiction I can't imagine that that was
just that was the worst addiction yeah
opioid I mean they're the worst and so I
can't imagine that that was just so as
simple as saying okay okay well now I'm
this time I'm gonna do it so what what
was the thought and do you can you take
us back to that moment where you kind of
realized okay I'm gonna do this or was
it many false starts before it finally
happened how did it happen
yeah no that's an excellent point that
there were many false thoughts no one
who's suffering with addiction wants to
continue to wallow in that because
they call those uh medication Percocet
like painkillers but they're really Joy
Killers so it what happens is you
initially take them you feel great and
you can maybe do that for like a week
and every single time you take a a dose
you get a euphoric feeling maybe the
first time for an hour or two by the end
of the first week it might be a half an
hour by the time you're in this Rose of
addiction you're only taking them so
you're not sick and I mean anyone who
knows anything about withdrawals from
opioids knows like I'm talking imagine
having the worst flu of your life for
seven freaking days and it can stop
whenever you're ready to start taking
them again or are you strong enough to
get through this week to 10 days so then
again just like quitting at anything
you're sick oh something came up any
justification where you're like I can't
afford to show up here in like the
throws of withdrawals I like can't go
two feet from the toilet because I might
have to use the bathroom I'm sweating
then I'm freezing cold everything hurts
I'm an emotional mess I could try it
like a drop of a dime and um so there
had been many I had gotten sober for
weeks and months at a time and then you
know found excuses to go back to using
but when we were adopting my children I
was like I cannot live like this with
children I have to be in my right mind I
I and yeah it was in his so to your
point it's not just like I just switched
this uh a switch flipped the switch but
I will say in terms of being hard
finding someone that's been able to get
sober from opioids is like finding
someone like with a story like from The
Biggest Loser where you see someone who
weighs like 350 400 pounds then the next
time you see them they're ripped to
shreds and they're living like an
athletic lifestyle that's I think how
rare it is to find someone who was
heavily addicted to opioids and is now
living a clean and prosperous
emotionally prosperous life that's how I
feel it's it's it's so hard and only
other junkies who've been through this
can recognize the struggle that went
into it and the strength that it took to
get out of it like I said I've not
always been perfect but I'm so grateful
and thankful to be where I am for us is
where I was with regards to the
addiction but yeah it was not it it
I know I'm Different I know when it
comes to mindset I know
that I have some mental strength that
other people don't have I say that with
humility but it's the truth I I just
decided I'd rather die than live like
this and I don't want to die
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets
serve dueling databases HubSpot grow
better
you have an interesting perspective
because you grew up with a bunch of
people that are now in prison and you
weren't in a prison then you worked in
uh in New York on Wall Street but uh now
you know a lot of these like uh you know
these celebrity Fitness folks so you
have like a you know a bunch of
interesting people and you also work
with Teddy Atlas which I imagine through
that you've been able to meet Tyson and
it looks like you have Dustin Poirier on
the on on your behind your shoulder on a
picture of him so you've met a lot of
like traditionally tough people or at
least people who from an outsider's
perspective from my perspective are like
these tough guys who are some of the
toughest people that you've met and you
admire when you think about how would
this person behave in this situation
when I'm struggling
physically or mentally
I would think one of the toughest people
I know I don't want to get emotional
one of the toughest people I know is my
wife
the fact that she was able to like stick
with me through all this [__] for
the
for the sake of my children
has been uh incredible it's easy to be
physically tough because like I said I
mean he catching a beat in his like okay
I got beat up like okay not the end of
the world we've all been falling down a
bike crash car accident whatever like
physical pain is just momentary
emotional pain lasts forever someone
that's able to withstand emotional pain
and show toughness and perseverance
through emotional pain is a special
person because like I said with like
using addiction as an example there's a
lot of ways to escape emotional pain
drugs alcohol ultimately they're all
shortcuts and um
you know like a finger in the dike of
the problem like the only way through it
the only way to deal with adversity is
to go through it and go through the fire
you know like uh the expression When
You're Going Through Hell keep going or
you're in a hole stop digging So to that
extent in terms of emotional toughness
my wife showed incredible
um conviction and perseverance to stick
with me when I was just
of a mediocre Finance clown
addicted to drugs behaving like an
[__] worrying about materialistic
possessions and worrying about keeping
up with the Joneses versus worry about
just living for myself and trying to be
the best person that I could be which in
my heart is like who I really am and um
so to that extent my wife is tough but
you know in terms of traditional
toughness
I'd say any of the fighters we've had on
the podcast that's um Dustin over one
shoulder in our Regis over this Regis
program who's um 140 pound world
champion
um those are two incredibly tough guys
but anyone who has the courage to get
into the ring or the octagon and have a
fist fight for money in front of other
people
can you imagine anything physically
tougher than that I just I have such
those guys how do those guys describe
that I mean like this weekend I don't
know how many people bought the Jon
Jones fight but I imagine he had
millions of eyeballs on him he's like
well I'm gonna get in my underwear I'm
gonna basically I'm basically naked and
I'm like gonna fight to the death in
front of all these people that's right I
and like I've read some like Channel sun
in and cowboy Cerrone they're like
backstage they you they're these tough
guys and they like at the weigh-ins
they're puffing their chest and they're
flexing their muscles and they're like
I'm gonna F and kill you yada yada but
then they'll tell stories once they're
retired they're like
I had to throw up in the backstage ahead
of that fight because I was so afraid
and at the beginning of every fight it's
just like a race you have these feelings
of like what am I doing I don't want to
do this why do I keep doing this what am
I like this is the worst feeling and so
they're kind of human but what do you
think or what have some of those people
said right before they're about to get
in the the arena and just fight to the
death what's that what do they go
through you just hit the nail on the
head I've had some fights myself uh
boxing matches and it's whether you're
in the UFC or fighting in a um a VFW or
a convention hall
every single person that I've ever met
and spoken to and I've been in the
locker room of Fighters before fights
many world champions UFC boxers Teddy
and I trained the light heavyweight
champion of the world I was basically
Teddy's assistant Teddy trained him but
we were in the locker room for a
pay-per-view Main Event fight and I can
tell you every single person feels the
same things that you and I would feel or
that average person would feel they're
not different they're not special
they're not unique
the coward and the hero as Teddy Alice
would say they feel the same exact thing
the only thing that they do differently
is how they behave some people let that
fear oval overwhelm them and they cower
and like I I I I I compare it to like
surfing the waves are crashing down and
there's that like break Zone where you
either have to get out of the water or
get through the break
and the coward
either gets washed out the sea or goes
back to the shore and the hero goes
through the break and knows that on the
other side is calm Waters and is the
place where you want to be with other
Heroes so I think to answer your
question is they don't feel any
different everyone feels the same thing
they're not immune to the fact that
there's millions of people watching no
one is it's just exactly as you would
imagine the only difference is how they
behave and you just forget her that the
what this reason they train you train as
hard as you do or they do is because
at the end of the day you've got to
block out all the [__] because all
that fear that we we've just described
is all noise and the the amount of
things and again this is all knowledge I
have gleaned from working with Teddy
Atlas all of the scenarios and potential
nightmares that could happen
Teddy calls them like the ninjas of your
mind the ninja stop coming over the wall
as you're getting ready to go into the
Ring of the octagon and all of the
possible scenarios endless scenarios of
things that could go horribly wrong you
could die you could get knocked out you
could get your arm broken
but at the end of the day what are the
odds of any of those things happening
because you know you've trained like a
dog you've been in fires with these kind
of sparring sessions you've done the
running you've done the training and at
the end of the day you have to block out
the fact that everyone's watching this
is now simply a more aggressive sparring
session and you've just got to focus on
the task at hand and once at least in my
own experience whether it's a fight or a
race once the gun goes off or the bell
rings and you start jabbing or running
you have to get your mind into that
place of like hey I've been here before
I know what's coming I know what to do
even if it's not going right I know how
I'm supposed to behave and Teddy would
say you know
the difference what makes a fighter a
fighter or what makes a fight a fight is
when there's something to overcome
you're not really a fighter if you're
just in there beating the brakes out of
[__] competition you become a fighter
when there's something to overcome when
you adult some cards that you weren't
expecting when you get punched in the
most in a shot that you didn't see
coming and now you're tested that's when
you see who's really a fighter who can
come back who can get off the canvas we
measure a man much more by how they get
off the canvas versus how many times
they knock someone else to the canvas so
when you have losses and setbacks and
you've experienced that feeling of
having quit or not given a hundred
percent that's when you find out who you
really are and that's at least that's
what's worked for me and again a lot of
reality the reality of situation isn't
nearly as important as the narrative
that you have in your head because the
narrative in your head is going to
control how you behave and control your
mindset and that's something that's well
within your control and you can learn
how to harness that ability over time
and through practice and that's why we
train the way we do
so I wanted to ask you about that exact
thing because uh
you know not you've you run and you run
these crazy marathons in these crazy
times I think basically just been
getting faster and faster every year you
know every year since you were 35 years
old which is kind of amazing I'm not
gonna run I'm not a runner it's not
something that's of interest to me
but everybody hits adversity so I think
this is probably the most important
thing that I want to learn from you
which is
uh when you whether you're in a fight or
you're in a race and adversity strikes
what is the self-talk
that you have developed that gets you
through that because uh you said the
difference between like a coward and the
hero is the behavior but I think the
behavior I would guess comes from
a conversation in that happens in your
head deciding which way are we going to
go are we going to walk off the field or
are we going to continue on right um and
so what is that self-talk and how do you
train that
yeah that's a great point and um I think
that at the end of the day we all know
what the answer is I like try to use a
professional analogy like a business
analogy if you're a research analyst
right and you're covering a particular
stock and you know that there's like
let's say realistically 15 other guys
covering that stock is like who's gonna
go the extra mile to get it done right
we've all just like at the start of race
everyone shows up everyone there is good
everyone there is fit who's the
healthiest that's a big difference
who's done all the little things so if
you're doing research have you uncovered
every every stone have you turned over
every stone like um Warren Buffett talks
about that he would pour through company
reports I don't even think he uses a
computer he's just old school he's just
reading reading company reports reading
balance sheets and I think that we all
know whether it whatever our profession
is we all know what we could do better
and I think when you sit with yourself
and you ask yourself have I done
everything think about how much free
time how much time we waste in the day
and and if you need an example every
single time you open your phone and look
at it for anything Instagram Twitter I
do it myself it pisses me off because
it's such a waste of time I've like
contemplated getting rid of social media
every day for like the last two years
but it's it it I would be lying if I
didn't say it's been helpful me to me in
terms of getting my message out there
and kind of sharing some of the
knowledge I have in terms of what I've
been able to do with running but I would
say that
to simplify is like we all know what
needs to be done you just have to do the
little extra things that you know that
other people aren't is someone else
leaving early to go have drinks with
their friend the people who are great
that's their priority and again back to
the concept of all in if you're all in
on one thing and you decide there's one
thing that no one's going to beat me at
no one has to tell you what you need to
do you know everyone you know spend more
time doing the thing that you love doing
if you do something more than anyone
else I'm pretty sure you'll become the
best in the world that if you want to be
the best piano player
there's going to be people that are just
virtuosos so let's take out the outliers
but if you want to be a piano player and
and there's 20 other people in your
class I promise you that if you train
more than them and practice more than
them you'll be the best and I
unfortunately the only example I have
about for me is running
um I've just run more than other people
and I've been able to stay healthy which
is you know I get maybe part of it is
luck I just have the physiology that
absorbs the miles but I do a lot of
other things to maintain my overall
health in addition to running you you
keep saying that you're like this you're
like I'm a humble guy you know and it
feels crazy well you don't say I'm
humble I think you said I don't want to
be a narcissist and talk about this and
that but you kind of are like this Alpha
cocky guy in a good way that's a
compliment uh because I read this story
and he you just you're a funny guy
you're like
you're like the character you're like
the real life version of mar of a Mark
Wahlberg character in a movie because
you say these these these funny Wise
Cracks because I read the story that's
like 10 years old apparently Lance
Armstrong was hosting like a man camp or
some type of like you know like tough
guy camp and uh I think the story is is
that like you were kind of chirping at
him you're like uh I came this close you
told the the reporter I came this close
to beating Lance Armstrong in the first
race I attacked him like a rabbit dog I
had a gap on him and then on the ride
apparently a rock hit Lance or something
from one someone's tires and you said I
heard Lance Armstrong I broke him I made
him bleed and then you actually uh you
got close to beating him or maybe even
did beat him and he said I'm the winner
of man camp Lance I need you to clean my
bike and hose it off for me yes yeah the
initial quote says slightly out of
context because it sounds a bit like a
dork like I would never be like I came
this close to beat him I just would
never talk like that there was more to
the quote or I was and I did beat him in
a couple of those clients but he
probably hadn't written bike in like six
months before we did this together so
like there's a lot of context that's
missed in there but Lance is a good
friend of mine a rock did bounce up and
hit his finger and I said yep I made you
bleed now clean all the bikes we kicked
your ass and uh and then I probably said
to him make sure that no one gets a
blood sample that uh make sure no one
gets a drop of that blood and runs a
sample on it I don't want to find out
that you're still doing any kind of
performance enhancers but it was
obviously set in jest but but you're
you're chirping at them in a fun way but
even like even that you had the
confidence to chirp at him a little bit
I think it's hilarious and awesome why
wouldn't I he's a bike rider have you
ever met a bike rider that was gonna
physically like do anything to anyone I
was like I think at some point I said to
him like you're used to dealing with
like 115 pound European cyclists now
you're dealing with real men like this
is where peers there's no like you know
what I mean I can't imagine a less
intimidating group of guys than
professional cyclists sounds like you
better took Lance to band camp actually
instead of him yeah
classes in session that day the other
thing is if someone heard all the
conversations out of context number one
they wouldn't be fit to be published
they were like very
um much like a locker room but Lance is
my buddy and and all of that set stuff
was just said and just and teasing each
other that probably wouldn't all be for
public consumption but
um you know I I anytime you see quotes
where it's like that like I came this
close to being Lance it makes me sound
like a [__] dork and like I wouldn't
talk like that I would have said I'm
gonna kick your ass and when we get out
there tomorrow I'm gonna do this and I'm
gonna do that but again I would say that
too I'd tell Dustin Poirier the same
thing if we were going to have a
sparring session I just that's but
that's all and I I don't I don't want to
sound I I don't at all I don't feel
cocky or arrogant whatsoever I know that
there's some things I'm good at and I
know that there's a lot more things that
I'm bad at so if I've come across this
cocky I apologize it's certainly not the
message I want to send I I think I tried
to be as humble as I can and know that
there's a lot of things that I'm not
good at but suffering is one thing that
I know how to do
are you making most of your income right
now from your main I think you have like
a like a small advisory right are you
making most of your income now from that
or are you and are you going to try and
go full transition to become like this I
don't know what the right word is what
we call these Goggins but whatever that
is a personality that sounds like Lamer
than it actually is but you know what I
mean yeah I know um that's a great
question so I've made the most of my
income through finance and um what I've
done so so in 2015 I left New York I
went to California with a fintech
startup
um called electronify we were brokering
trades between
um
institutions for corporate bonds so
right now when you trade a corporate
bond you have to call like Goldman
Morgan Stanley and you have to find they
they you tell them I want to sell these
balloons they find a buyer sometimes
they'll buy them from you which was the
old traditional Investment Bank model
right they hey I got 20 20 million of
these bonds to go okay we'll take them
there and then they try to sell them at
a slight markup now they're basically
just matching buyers and sellers for all
intensive so we created a new uh an
electronic Marketplace that could let
these like Fidelity and Pimco trade
directly with each other so I went out
to new I went out to LA to cover the
West Coast knowing that there was a good
chance that this startup wasn't going to
work it didn't we sold it to a
competitor but I my by moving to La I
basically forced myself into an
uncomfortable position because there
aren't sales and trading jobs in La like
there are in New York so I knew I'd have
to figure something else out and you
know that expression of like hey if
you're waiting for everything to be
perfect to make a move it ain't ever
going to happen you have to make the
move and make it perfect and long story
short I was riding my bike out
everything that good in my life that's
happened has been through Endurance
Sports I was riding my bike with a guy
on my neighborhood and we were um
he ran an asset management firm called
the Palisades group and they had maybe
two billion in assets under management
they were running money for all big
household managers like all the
household names like Apollo for instance
and and they had separately managed
accounts so the fees weren't huge like a
traditional hedge fund or asset manager
and I said to him he didn't have a uh um
any business development he wasn't
actively out there trying to raise more
Capital which is what he would need to
do to really grow his business so I said
let me run business development for you
and and he said you know accurately you
don't have any experience and we're
friends I don't want to put you in a
losing position and I said okay I'll
work for free for three months just to
see if it works and again every time
I've been willing to take a bet on
myself it's worked out in that in that
brokerage commission role that we
discussed earlier I was paid just
straight commission so when I was making
all that money if I didn't do any trades
I don't make any money
but because I was willing to do that I
got to keep more of the commissions so
anytime I've been on myself it's worked
thankfully so he gave me an opportunity
and I came in and in two years we grew
that from two billion to 5 billion I
raised uh two discretionary funds which
is basically like raising a hedge fund
first time manager managing
discretionary Capital we couldn't even
hire Banks to help us raise the money
they basically laughed us out of the
room and I said they said to me you
think why do you think and I they said
why do you think you can raise this fund
like it doesn't seem like you'll be able
to just based on the track record
experienced asset class and I said why
do you think you can't like until
someone beats me at the New York
Marathon like I'll convince myself that
I can win this whole race and long story
short we raised the money we raised a 35
million dollar fund and 150 million
dollar fund and once I did that and kind
of started to believe in myself that I
could raise money
my boss at the time who's like one of my
best friends Jack McDowell who's like
okay like just go off and go off and do
this on your own he said dude you're
wasting your time go do your own thing
and the first mandate that I worked on
was with um David Sinclair at a life
biosciences I helped them raise 50
million dollars at one point David and I
were raising capital in New York and we
had dinner with um Wendy Murdock and um
Tony Blair and Bennett Miller at Wendy's
like uh New York City Triplex apartment
of Fifth Avenue it was literally like I
was watching someone's else's life
unfold as I was sitting there having a
conversation with Tony Blair over dinner
and um so once I had once I had raised
money for a few different independent uh
private placement mandates I just
started doing that full time and have
since worked on a bunch of um mandates
in the health and wellness space and now
I'm back raising a um on a consultant
basis raising a third discretionary fund
for the Palisades group and um so that's
kind of one way that I make money I also
have some invest I've invested in a lot
of these deals I have some advisory
roles
um I mean I guess for lack of better
terms some influencer deals
um with some big brands that have been
you know I just feel so incredibly lucky
that Brands want to affiliate with me
it's like a dream come true and then I
also have a TV project I'm working on
what's the next like five years gonna be
how's this transition going to look like
and what do you want it to look like
well in a perfect world I just filmed a
pilot
um with a big production company for a
network that's um confidential right now
but if if the network likes what we
recorded and I think they will it's
unbelievable I think a lot of people
will like it
it's a non-scripted kind of
show
um with where I'm ho I'm the Hope Maine
host and um
in a perfect world the network will like
the show pick it up and I will do that
and see where that takes me but I I like
the idea
I always tell people like when you work
for someone else when you're employed
you're kind of a slave like they own you
you can't just do whatever you want to
do you get to have a couple days off a
week they provide a little bit of safety
for you and in turn you give them like x
amount of your time
but the main thing that you miss out on
by being an employee is you miss out on
the opportunity to pursue interesting
opportunities when they are presented
like this media project I'm working on
if I had a job there's no way I'd be
able to do it because they were like Hey
we're going to record for a week and you
know out of town I would never have been
able to do this but because I was
willing to bet on myself and you know
take the risk of having to get my own
health insurance not being sure if like
you know something happens to me and
people don't want to be affiliated with
me anymore I get injured I can't run
like okay now it's what I do I guess I
could always fall back on a finance gig
but I don't want to do that I wasn't
happy doing that and to that point
I've said this before and I think it's
relevant for this podcast is that I've
said to people like money doesn't make
you happy and people are always like oh
[__] you have money and I'm like no
I've had money and lost money multiple
times when Enron went bust
you know when you're making a lot of
money you spend a lot of money and when
that ends abruptly you very quickly out
of money especially if you have a ten
twelve thousand dollar mortgage and now
you get paid getting paid 10 grand a
month which is what happened to me when
Enron went bust things can change
quickly and the reason I say the example
I give you is
I was making a ton of money and I became
a drug addict so it didn't make me
happier it caused me different anxiety
so money can alleviate a lot of stress
but it can also add stress that you
didn't know stressors that you didn't
even know existed and yes it's easier to
have money than to not have money but if
your only goal in life is to make money
I would say be careful what you wish for
because I was making money and I could
have convi I could have comfortably
continued to do what I was doing but I'm
so much happier now wearing the risk of
not knowing where the next deal or
paycheck is going to come from but I've
never been happier in my life and and
this didn't this transformation didn't
happen until my late 40s and when I
finally like had the courage to battle
myself full like all in in my late 40s
it's been the greatest gift I've ever
given myself is to like bet on myself
and and and and live and die with my own
results
so in five years I hope that this Media
stuff becomes more of a reality and I
can continue to kind of share my
experiences and um
you know knowledge of you know knowing
how to suffer and deal with adversity
and uh I like I like sharing that
message I've done some speaking recently
that's also contributed to uh my
financial well-being and that's
something that I actually really enjoy
which is crazy right because every time
I do speak to people I go hey is anyone
here get nervous about speaking in front
of an audience and every single person
raises their hand and I go guess what I
do too but I'm dealing with it and like
I tell my kids it's okay to be scared
like when they my youngest son's playing
baseball he's like Dad I get so nervous
when I get up to batty seven I said
buddy everybody does but sometimes we
just have to learn how to do things
while we're scared once you get
comfortable uh operating while you're
scared
you can't lose it's just it has to do
with repetitions and experience how are
you so I'm a former competitive Runner
now I'm I'm I just I'm pretty into
fitness but all types of well-rounded
Fitness stuff and
I get hurt you seem like you do not get
hurt is that and part of that I think is
like just biology I think some people
just built where they can absorb miles
like you said but what are you doing to
stay healthy
um I try to sleep eight hours a day I
eat a very healthy diet I do a lot of
strength training that I think a lot of
Runners don't do
um and I do a lot of recently I hadn't
done a lot of stretching and stuff in
the past but lately I've been doing a
lot more stretching and um
I feel like it's especially in the last
like six to 12 months tons of um
preventative care electrical musculus
I've got every like met device Under the
Sun electrical muscular stimulation
theragon etc etc it's been um I spent a
lot of time trying to keep myself
healthy but it gets getting harder over
the years
do you think that you know running 70
and 80 miles a week do you think that
that's going to be that's going to make
you a live a longer or healthier life or
are you just happy to do you just like
how it makes you feel because when I you
know think about like some of these I
did a half Ironman nothing like you did
and I didn't even do it fast but I
remember doing all these miles and I'm
like man I don't know if this is gonna
if this is gonna make me live to be 120
it might not like or maybe just like
lifting weights and going for walks
might be a little bit better but how do
you think about that I agree with you
100 100
I always tell
anyone who's interested I don't know
that this is the answer for me but
you're talking to someone who is living
the life of a drug addict to me okay if
it makes my life a little bit shorter
but it's adding the quality of life that
I'm experiencing right now that's a bet
I'm willing to make
um
yeah I don't know like I wish I had an
answer for you I don't know what's going
to add to my overall longevity
um in terms of my mental and physical
well-being
um but I know that right now this is the
best way for me to live my life look at
what it's given me has been
it's been immeasurable
um but I think that there are a lot of
things that contribute to longevity I
mean obviously there's the famous
longevity study out of Harvard that
suggests that the most important element
to live in a healthy fruitful life is um
relationships and um it's to that extent
the one thing that this lifestyle and my
kind of Newfound station in life has
provided me is the quality of
relationships when I worked in finance
this doesn't apply to everyone in
finance but a lot of the people I worked
with were real [__] and I didn't
like them and it was keeping up with the
Joneses and I if I never had to sit on a
trading desk for the rest of my life I'd
be perfectly fine with that
um again not everyone I met some people
there that I genuinely love but this is
the most also some people there that if
I saw them I wouldn't mind giving them a
smack in the mouth there's been some
real idiots I've worked with and I I
could go on forever
um but
my life now when I if there's someone in
my life that I don't appreciate or don't
respect I can just cut them out and move
on to the next thing I don't need
the thing that I have that some
billionaires don't have is enough I have
enough I have everything I need and I'd
love to have more money and I'd love to
put in a pool and renovate my house and
splurge on a lot of [__] but at the
end of the day I have the one thing that
I need and that's enough and I have my
family and
um so
you know Finding what you're finding
something in life that you're
passionatable and that you genuinely Joy
enjoy is the key and to me and people
say all the time find something you love
doing and you'll never work a day in
your life there isn't a single week that
goes by that I don't say to my wife can
you believe I don't have an effing job
am I the luckiest person we know and she
always laughs and goes you're definitely
the luckiest person I know
but it's interesting that the harder I
work the luckier I seem to get
you're an interesting guy and we
appreciate you coming on your uh I've
been following you now I think since
2020 whenever you joined Teddy Atlas
yeah because I I listen to that a ton I
know Sean knows too and so we appreciate
you coming on your uh
you're different you're built different
you're a different guy and we appreciate
that we like those types of people well
I I want to say again thank you so much
I really hope that I didn't come across
as uh two alpha or cocky I just tried to
be more than anything I tried to just be
honest man is like the the the world and
the internet is so big if you if you
embellish or [__] about something
there'll be someone coming out of the
bushes like that didn't happen and this
didn't happen because I know a lot of my
stuff sounds Sensational and crazy but
I'm like I think if anything at times
I'm downplaying some of the stuff
because I know it's how crazy it sounds
but um yeah anyway I I do feel very
humbled and honored to be here this is a
place where Cockiness and alphaness is
actually appreciated so so even if you
did that would be uh you know right at
home here we just like when people are
the way they are and not trying to be
it's at home because by the way we don't
get a lot of Cockiness or Alpha shot
that's why we like it yeah we enjoy it
it's a good change you know we're a
business podcast for the most part
entrepreneurship and uh
you know we're a bunch of people with
carpal tunnel syndrome you know it's not
a bunch of Health males coming on the
Pod uh typically uh so so you know I
think there was some good stuff here for
for
mental strength toughness adversity you
know basically uh what I think is the
most important thing which is the little
managing the little voice in your head
and uh that little voice in your head
you know that's who you you go through
life with and I think that
um you're a great example of what
happens when you really like you know
work on that and so so thanks for coming
on again I really appreciate it I would
say this before I leave like that voice
in your head is not little
that voice in your head is all all
powerful the most powerful right it's
the voice in my head is the one that
tells me to get high when I know I
shouldn't the voice in the head the
little voice tells me to go run when
it's pissing rain or freezing cold and
snowing so that voice in your head
shouldn't be little it should be big and
it should be like screaming from a
megaphone that you're the best and you
can do anything you want to do and to
your point if you have a bunch of carpal
tunnel guys here that like might
consider themselves nerds and like
intellects good because the one thing
that you can control is your physical
actions anyone can do what I've done I
promise you I'm not special I wish I had
the intellect that some of these carpal
tunnel guys because that's the one thing
I don't have and that's where I'm trying
to overcompensate by being so physical
that maybe my intellectual shortcomings
can be overcome through physical
intimidation and uh alphanus but anyway
I say that in chess but honestly
everything that I have is available to
anyone I'm just literally the only thing
I'm doing different than most people is
physically is trying harder well
Sam I don't know about you but uh in 10
minutes I'm going to do my workout and I
think it's going to be a good one today
I think I got a little extra juice
no I think you know it is but you gotta
Follow You Gotta follow him on Instagram
there's videos of him Shadow Boxing and
uh right before he's about to go running
or right after he got uh got done
running and he uh I always feel foolish
Post in that [__] I really do and then
I'm like no I like it I watch it because
I like running a lot but I don't want a
runner's body and you're you're you're
cool because you don't have a runner's
body my mission in life is to not look
like a runner you're well-rounded you're
well-rounded it doesn't matter if you're
53 or you're 23 you look you look you
look good you know I always I joke I'm
like the point of working out for me is
uh to be able to uh kill or outrun
everyone in a room you know you want to
be able to kill it eat them or outrun
them and we'll add a third thing which
is you also want to look good naked and
so in your and you're and you're and
you're checklist it's check check check
all right you're not gonna look good for
yourself think about your spouse so
that's kind of my closing Salvo
all right you're the man thank you very
much we appreciate that I appreciate you
guys thank you for having me
[Music]
thank you